so i'm at the store trying to shop right
now
no pictures in the store oh it's not a
picture it's a video you would not keep
your mask up now it is up for the video
no no here please read the store i was
trying to smell these candles here to
shop at dollarama here
as i pull my mask down to smell
and now i have another guy
yelling at me over here to put my mask
up
unbelievable man bring that knot down i
literally was trying to smell a candle
so canada first of all is that canadian
flag right there yeah we need to invade
our neighbor to the north to
re-establish freedom we'll be greeted as
liberators they're not even a real
country anyway i would guarantee you
that the guy who's yelling at him about
masking is quadruple vexed quintupled
acts sex tuple dax infinity that and
they're all freaking out for no reason
at all it's his store he can do what he
wants also
that guy is uh disconnected from reality